hi everyone Persia here and in this
video we're checking out some of the
absolute coolest recreations we've seen
from the community so far from Studio
Ghibli - Evan intend Oh favourite and
everything in between
prepare to be mind blown this list is in
no particular order so let's get to it
for all of you Ghibli fans out there get
ready to run the Able's because the
first recreation will make you want this
custom design ready user is zap J posted
a few shots of their boiler room
recreation from spirited away they use
iron and star fragments to add to the
sprite illusion but my favorite part has
to be the mannequin head with the
glasses to represent Komachi if you are
surprised to see a creative use for
dropping iron on the floor then the smex
design will really make you think
twitter user a truly Larry Liu has not
only recreated this beautiful scroll
painting from the 2008 Beijing Olympics
but completed the look of the scroll by
using 2 natural log benches at both ends
this combined with the detail and
shading of the custom design is genius
I'm sure you've heard your villagers
talk about roles they'd play in a movie
but a Twitter user at oh so precious 16
took it a step further by recreating an
entire scene straight from Parks and Rec
from the camera angles and reactions to
the casting itself they not this
recreation out of the park okay let's
not fight I broke it let me pay for it
run No who broke it
our Islands tend to be an expression of
ourselves and our favorite places
Iggy 5 to 4 on YouTube showcased just
that by recreating Shibuya crossing and
one of their favorite places in Japan
the details and the street markets even
have Raymond's approval we have got the
link to Iggy's full island swords down
below speaking of favorites the next
recreation put ocarina of time on the
top of my list of games to revisit as
soon as possible
accurately named twitter user at hyrule
underscore game posted a video
walkthrough of their recreation of the
castle courtyard level in ocarina of
time ultimately leading up to zelda
herself this video it makes me smile
every time hold on to your pokeballs
because this next recreation is super
effective at keno pika on twitter shared
their pokemon gold and silver island
which was modeled head-to-toe after the
johto region we see special cameos from
Pokemon like Snorlax and Gyarados but
the best part of all is that they share
each and every code with us at the end
of the tour you already know we've got
the link to those in the description it
has been an amazing surprise to see what
creative things Animal Crossing players
are coming up with every day have you
seen any mind-blowing recreations so far
share them in the comments because I
want to see you if you like this video
then check out our two-part tour of
inspiring islands that we have up on
gamespot right now see you next time
you
[Music]